efectivamente el país está sumado en
esta crisis dada por esta vacunación que
se ha dado de forma irregular a altos
funcionarios del ex gobierno y del
actual gobierno hasta el momento se
tiene conocimiento que se ha vacunado el
ex presidente martín vizcarra su esposa
su hermano también la ministra de
relaciones exteriores del actual
gobierno dos viceministros del
ministerio de salud de ocho funcionarios
de cancillería y también funcionarios
del ministerio de salud del país estamos
en esta investigación porque las 3.200
dosis que ingresaron al país representan
alrededor de 1500 personas que se fueron
a ver vacunados esto tiene que ir ser
investigado y desde el congreso peruano
estamos justamente en este proceso de
buscar esclarecer
con claridad a cuánto ha involucrado
esta vacunación
que puede estar detenida con temas de
corrupción no claro que sí pero también
cuéntenos qué significa esta nueva
crisis política para perú que lleva años
en la inestabilidad y hasta dónde llega
la corrupción entonces en el país de
acuerdo a lo que usted mismo nos cuenta
bueno es una situación sumamente
complicada para el país nos encontramos
en la primera fase de vacunación hace
unos días llegó el segundo lote de
vacunas de sino par para completar el
primer millón de dosis que ha comprado
el estado peruano en esta negociación de
38 millones esta negociación que desde
el congreso hemos venido exigiendo que
se dé de forma pronta con los diferentes
laboratorios desde el año pasado se
venía negociando desde el mes de julio
con la de la farmacéutica pfizer y no se
pudo concretar nada pese a tener el 17
de septiembre firmado un acuerdo previo
y poniendo en
en el mes de octubre haberse culminado
este este contrato haberse cerrado y
poder tener el desde el año pasado ya
dosis de otros laboratorios y es más o
menos fresco en lo que a horas por 300
asumo por menos de la mitad no es es un
tema que se debe esclarecer y entremos
desde el congreso hacerlo lo más pronto
posible